jadot yannick 54 ans candidat écologiste
vous menez votre deuxième campagne
présidentielle mais la première jusqu'au
bout puisque en 2017 vous étiez retirer
bonjour yannick jadot bonjour la
première image de vous à la télévision
date de 1986 et l'époque de la
mobilisation contre la loi devaquet on
vous découvre sur le plateau de michel
polac 19 ans déjà engagé avec d'autres
étudiants vous restez derrière vous ne
prenez pas encore la parole ni la
lumière mais avec votre maître 92 on ne
peut pas vous ratez
qu'elle était celui parmi vous parmi les
étudiants qui étaient avec jérôme
lorsqu'il a reçu sa grenade fonds chez
vous oui alors comment ça s'est passé
j'aimerais dire à van avant de commencer
tout débat qu'on aimerait
demandé une minute de silence pour tous
les blessés lit nord
c'est cette révolte de jeunesse qui vous
a donné le goût de l'engagement
j'étais déjà dans une famille très
politique on allait distribuer des
tracts coller des affiches gamin mais
c'est vrai que je pense que chaque
génération d'une certaine façon à son
à son rituel d'engagement politique et
c'est vrai que la mobilisation contre la
loi devaquet
les violences policières évidemment la
mort de malik oussékine ça forge sa
forge un caractère politique
militant vous allez l'être pendant des
années après des études d'économie à
paris-dauphine vous choisissez les ong
et vous devenez activistes on va vous
retrouver dans de multiples combats et
actions coup de poing notamment pour
greenpeace
tant pis on l'a fait une spécialité les
actions coup de poing pour une
couverture médiatique la plus large
possible mise ordonne de quitter les
lieux sous peine d'une
une amende considérable en période de
canicule on n'arrive plus à refroidir
les centrales on rejette dans les
rivières de l'autre est très chaude qui
a un vrai problème environnemental pour
les associations de protection de
l'environnement l'innocuité des ogm n'a
pas été suffisamment de montrer si on
considère qu'il ya des risques
potentiels et ben il faut appliquer le
principe de précaution deux militants de
greenpeace prennent d'assaut le
clemenceau qu'il juge hautement toxiques
la société qui a des amiantés le
clemenceau toulon on considère qu'il ya
encore 500 à 1000 tonnes d'amiante à
boire du thé manceau 7 heures du matin
autour du rainbow warrior la bataille
navale peut commencer les marins
pêcheurs lancent leur zodiac sur ceux de
vis sur place la gendarmerie maritime
n'intervient pas
c'est complètement fou c'est que ils
nous balancent des boulots que la
gendarmerie est là à 100 m et qu'elle ne
fait absolument rien alors qu'elle était
parfaitement prévu prévenu que les
thoniers senneurs avec faire cette
action après un moratoire de 14 ans
l'islande a repris depuis hier la chasse
à la baleine il n'y a absolument pas
besoin de tuer des cétacés pour les
étudier beaucoup d'animation devant la
base militaire de l'île longue après un
jeu de cache cache avec le commando de
marine trois écologistes pénètre dans
les eaux de la base à bord d'un zodiac
pour les contrevenants l'action est
symbolique le directeur des campagnes de
greenpeace france l'a rappelé
aujourd'hui en correctionnelle le
procureur qu'il n'entend pas ainsi a
requis pour chaque prévenu trois mois de
prison avec sursis une amende de 2000
euros ainsi que la confiscation du
zodiaque d'une valeur de 50 mille euros
ce coup d'éclat en zodiac pour avoir
tenté de pénétrer dans la base nucléaire
sous-marine de l'île l'on vous vaudra
une condamnation pour atteinte aux
intérêts supérieurs de la nation yannick
jadot la fin justifie t'elle tous les
moyens pas tous les moyens jamais la
violence jamais la violence contre des
personnes jamais la destruction des
biens mais il y avait un peu de violence
parfois non non non pas chez greenpeace
c'est justement les activistes sont
formés entraînés pour éviter justement
toute forme de violence parce que ça
cela remettra en cause la légitimité de
la dénonciation qui est fait à ce moment
là mais on voit bien c'est vrai que nous
avons arraché des ogm avec avec josé
bové et beaucoup d'autres c'était
illégal mais ça correspondait et ça
correspond toujours souhaits des
citoyens et maintenant c'est dans la loi
on peut pas produire peut pas cultiver
des ogm en france donc la loi la
légalité c'est aussi une construction
politique c'est une construction
citoyenne et parfois des actions peuvent
faire évoluer la loi dans le sens de
l'intérêt général parce qu'il ya des
nouvelles menaces par là et c'est ça le
c'est ça le rôle de greenpeace est sale
rôle aujourd'hui dell 214 c'est
totalement illégal d'aller filmer dans
des abattoirs qui sont fermés mais ça
participe de la prise de conscience ça
participe de l'évolution de la
réglementation et pour le coup là de la
suppression de la souffrance animale
donc c'est une bonne chose deux
militants activistes vous passez à la
politique 2009 vous avait 42 ans quand
le parti écologiste emmenée par dany
cohn-bendit obtient 16 % élections
européennes score historique avec 14
sièges d'eurodéputés dont le vôtre
ils ont fait la fête tard dans la nuit
les militants et les têtes de liste
après trente ans de travail on est entré
distille dans l'âge de la crédibilité
militant de la première heure
jeunes générations tous ont savouré ce
score auquel personne n'aurait osé
croire il ya encore quelques semaines
[Applaudissements]
c'est historique avoir un tel
pourcentage avoir autant d'électeurs
c'est vraiment la récompense d'une très
belle campagne je crois on sait jamais
laisser divertir sur les problèmes
franco français on a fait un vrai une
vraie campagne européenne a fait une
campagne de terrain faire de la
politique et ninja dos et plus efficace
que le militantisme de terrain pour
changer le monde
c'est un autre levier
vous savez vous l'avez dit moi ça fait
30 ans que j'ai le privilège incroyable
d'eau fondent
de faire de mes engagements de mes
convictions
mon métier mais mes occupations de tout
le temps donc c'est vrai c'est un
privilège mais j'ai l'impression de
poursuivre toujours le même combat
j'étais j'ai vécu en afrique j'ai vécu
au bangladesh j'ai participé à la
construction du mouvement
altermondialiste dans les années 90
j'ai fait greenpeace est en fait j'ai
l'impression de défendre toujours
l'écologie et la solidarité mais de le
faire avec des leviers différents
le parfois celle alerte d'autres fois
c'est la législation européenne est
maintenant évidemment c'est la volonté
la campagne électorale pour détenir
prendre le pouvoir mettre l'écologie au
coeur du pouvoir en france vous voici
donc dans le costume d'un député
européen mais pas dans l'habit d'un
notable on retrouve au coup de gueule
vos harangue comme encore récemment face
à emmanuel macron mais surtout celle
d'un combat gagné contre la pêche
électrique
nous avons un choix majeur à faire sur
la pêche électrique soit nous
poursuivons et nous généralisons 7
l'électrocution des fonds marins
décimant les poissons sacrifiant les
pêcheurs désertifier en automne au
territoire côtier soit nous interdisons
la pêche électrique cette arme de
prédation massive nous protégeons les
ressources nous sauvons la pêche
artisanale et nous avons de beaux et
beaux poissons dans nos assiettes alors
oui nous devons voter l'interdiction et
nous devons le faire malgré la
commission européenne parce que monsieur
le commissaire comme le reste de la
commission vous continuer à mentir sur
la pêche électrique vous mentez sur le
fondement scientifique de vos décisions
vous avez failli sur les dérogations il
n'y a aucun protocole scientifique sur
vos dérogation vous avez failli sur
l'expansion des dérogations qui en font
aujourd'hui une pêche passive alors pour
la pour la pêche artisanale pour les
océans pour les chefs cuisiniers qui
nous soutiennent pour les ong qui nous
soutiennent interdisons cette pêche
monsieur le commissaire vous devrez
rendre des comptes devant cette
assemblée bataille politique mémorable
victoire et grand motif de fierté et sur
les bancs aux
rares images de yannick jadot entre un
exalté
[Rires]
écoutez c'est vrai il faut il faut dire
son plaisir il faut le ressentir ça
libère parfois oui mais bien sûr bien
sûr parce que ce sont des combats
incroyables vous savez
régulièrement m'interroge pourquoi vous
êtes écolo alors il ya la question du
beau il ya la question de
l'émerveillement par la nature la beauté
des femmes et des hommes de ce que de ce
que l'humanité porte mais ces combats ce
combat contre la pêche électrique c'est
aussi un combat que nous avons mené avec
les pêcheurs artisans et ce sont des
métiers vous savez les métiers de la mer
sont des métiers parmi les plus
difficiles ce sont des métiers que vous
reprenez vous reprenez le bateau
de votre père de votre grand père c'est
lourd c'est des horaires infernaux cd
danger et c'est des gens qui
maintiennent des des territoires qui
maintiennent des manières de vivre des
modes de vie qui sont essentiels alors
c'est vrai que c'est un combat la pêche
électrique comme on a gagné aussi la
interdiction de la pêche en eau profonde
dans les dans les eaux européennes c'est
des combats pour la biodiversité on sait
à quel point c'est essentiel de protéger
les océans mais c'est des combats pour
des modes de vie c'est des combats pour
des femmes et des hommes qui qui mérite
toute notre attention et c'est vrai que
quand on gagne ce type de combat on sait
pourquoi on les gagne mais aussi aussi
on sait aussi pour qui on les gagne et
ça c'est fabuleux il est temps dans cet
adn
yannick jadot d'aller déterrer vos
racines
vous dites que vous êtes un picard et
que cela détermine votre caractère
réservé et pudique refusant l'exhibition
et la pipolisation de la vie publique
vos paysages d'enfance il ya donc de
l'a27 picardie où vous avez grandi avec
vos trois frères et vos parents
professeurs
la picardie cette ancienne province qui
n'a jamais pu se donner à un seul
département et qui a voulu appartenir à
4 connaît dans cette précocité ma
tanière une beauté calme et solide
le ciel ils possèdent des reflets
profond peut être provoquée par les
mille et un miroir des rivières et des
canaux et quand une caméra s'amuse à
découvrir la poésie sans autre but que
de mettre en images la rime des tons et
les alexandrins de l'harmonie est bien
là la picardie est merveilleuse
expliquez-nous yannick jadot en quoi
cette région et ses paysages forme ou
forge un caractère
ma la région de juin dans l'aisne
c'est une région agricole c'est une
région de ruralité c'est vrai que lee
compris moi mon grand-père était paysan
dans la tirage c'était vraiment les les
toutes petites fermes c'était dur donc
c'est un rapport à la terre qui vraiment
très profond qui est
ça fait partie de la vie ça fait partie
de la force ce sont des forêts qui sont
magnifiques véritablement magnifique la
forêt de saint-gobain et d'autre alors
je sais pas ces images viennent
peut-être du vimeu en tout cas plus du
côté de la somme et puis c'est un
patrimoine historique incroyable un
parfait un patrimoine architectural
moi ma ville de
là où j'ai j'ai été à l'école c'est laon
dans l'aisne c'est
ccd église c'est une cathédrale c'est
sont des remparts c'est une ville
absolument magnifique et puis
aujourd'hui
c'est beaucoup de
difficultés sociales de désertification
des des services publics donc c'est une
terre rude c'est une terre absolument
magnifique et elle fait partie de ma vie
parce que c'est le plus beau pays du
monde et est-ce qu'un picard pudique et
capable de fendre l'armure pour faire un
bon candidat à la présidentielle je sais
pas ce qu'est un bon candidat à
l'élection présidentielle en tout cas
j'espère que c'est d'abord quelqu'un qui
dans les propositions dont le projet
réponde à la fois aux difficultés du
quotidien parce que
nos compatriotes connaissent beaucoup et
puis qui accompagnent leurs aspirations
parce que la vie ce n'est pas que des
difficultés c'est des aspirations
individuelles et puis c'est un projet
c'est un projet pour la france une
élection présidentielle c'est s'est
passé d'une main du passé au futur
j'allais dire c'est ouvrir une nouvelle
page un nouveau chapitre de l'histoire
de france et quand on est picard on a
les pieds sur terre il ya une forme de
bon sens de rationalité on a les pieds
dans la terre et je pense qu'on n'a
jamais eu autant besoin que de retrouver
le lien avec la terre avec la nature
mais c'est aussi un regard sur l'horizon
c'est un regard sur l'europe c'est un
regard sur le monde parce que c'est
aussi ça être français c'est à la fois
être très ancrée avec des forts liens
d'appartenance y compris à des terroirs
mais c'est aussi
se penser comme une référence dans le
monde
c'est souvent exagérés mais on a été la
raison au xviiie siècle on a été la
démocratie au 19e siècle on a été les
conquêtes sociales au xxème siècle il y
avait plein de pays où c'est arrivé
on a toujours l'impression qu'on a été
l'avant garde et on aime toujours être
plus grand que nous mêmes ça doit être
une fierté et on doit retrouver sa honda
retrouver la fierté d'être d'être
nous-mêmes d'être français et de donner
un exemple pour le reste du monde et
évidemment pour moi vous l'avez compris
ça passe par l'écologie les pieds dans
la terre
parfois les fusil en l'air parce que la
picardie est une grande terre de chasse
certes voyez comment la la télévision en
parler en 75 images tournées à quelques
kilomètres de votre village d'enfance
avec les coups de fusil que vous avez
longtemps entendu résonner dans la
campagne
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est une chasse nous avons lancé dans
l'aisne nous avions jusqu'ici une chasse
sur hirson une chasse aux en plaine en
forêt nous avons voulu lancer dans
l'aisne une chasse aux canards notamment
ils devront trouver là un prix et à
therrien qui s'est intéressé cette
formule
nous pouvons prendre ici à fourdrain
une vingtaine de chasseurs à la journée
avec un prix de journée bien sûr qu'elle
est terminée par le prier terre
quel prix de la journée le prix de la
journée sera de 250 francs
[Applaudissements]
pardon pour tous ces coups de feu à vos
oreilles yannick jadot mauvais souvenir
oui enfin c'est pas que des souvenirs
c'est le présent vous savez quand je
suis dans ma picardie dans l'aisne le
samedi matin dimanche matin ça tire à
150 mètres de la maison donc
effectivement vous pouvez pas sortir
donc vous ne pouvez pas avoir accès à la
nature et puis c'est vrai que là ça
ressemble à ça ressemble à un massacre
en fait et puis c'est quand on était
gamins avec mes parents on fait toujours
mais on avait vraiment dans la forêt la
forêt magnifique et quand quand vous
voyez une harde avec insert superbe les
biches vous voyez les chevreuils tentant
on peut voir un renard ou des sangliers
c1 c'est fabuleux enfin j'veux dire
c'est pour moi ça reste à chaque fois un
m'émerveille mans et imaginer qu'en fait
un cerf aussi majestueux deviennent au
fond une cible qu'on va abattre et qu'on
va tuer pour le plaisir parce qu'y
compris la chasse à courre c'est même
pas pour manger la viande puisque il ya
ce qu'on appelle la cure et finalement
vous la donner au chien il ya quelque
chose qui me va pas donc effectivement
jeu
il faut il faut que tout le monde puisse
accéder à la nature il faut que les
chasse cruelle s'arrête
et que et qu'on respecte les animaux
parce que respecter les animaux c'est
aussi c'est aussi se respecte est en
fête et donc le refus ou la détestation
de la chasse qui est inscrit dans votre
programme il est non j'ai pas inscrit
dans mon programme la détestation de la
chasse le refuge as j'ai inscrit mon
programme le fait que l'achat serait
interdite et le week end et pendant les
vacances scolaires pour que toutes les
familles et y compris les chasseurs
évidemment sans leurs fusils puissent
profiter de la nature parce qu'on a
besoin de la nature et qu'elle est
magnifique mais ça c'est ancré depuis
l'enfance ça c'est ancré depuis
l'enfance parce que c'est vrai que
c'est pas enfin c'est la nature les
animaux ça fait partie du beau et j'ai
toujours du mal à consac comprendre
qu'on puisse vouloir tuer le bo voilà il
ya quelque chose avec qui qui qui qui
qui m'interroge toujours jeudi savait si
je peux me permettre
l'un des bouquins qui m'a vraiment
façonner ses les racines du ciel de
romain gary et vous savez dans ce
bouquin qui est extraordinaire que tout
le monde j'espère lire ah si vous n'avez
pas lu
c'est ce type il sort des camps de
concentration et puis va en afrique
sauver les éléphants il va pas
simplement en afrique sauver des enfants
parce qu'il veut protéger des animaux
c'est parce que l'éléphant est le plus
gros mammifère qu' il est d'une certaine
façon anachronique dans le monde où on
vit par sa taille par ses déplacements
et ce combat pour la défense des
éléphants c'est le combat de l'humanité
en fait c'est le combat pour la
diversité c'est le combat pour l'autre
c'est le combat pour la différence et
c'est un c'est l'écologie pour moi c'est
l'humanisme en fait nous sommes aussi
pour cet adn allez chercher vos mentors
[Musique]
nous avons cherché nous n'avons pas
beaucoup trouvé une figure tout de même
qui a marqué toute votre génération
yannick jadot nelson mandela héros de la
lutte anti apartheid en afrique du sud
27 années de prison jusqu'à ces images
bouleversantes et historique de sa
libération 90
nelson mandela tenant sa famille et leur
donne ses premiers pas d'homme libre
puis premiers pas hésitants comme
surpris de la foule venue attendre
la dernière barrière franchie ses
parents sa prison du monde extérieur à
15h15 à paris
l'instant historique qu'il ait fait un
27 ans 6 mois et 6 jours et captivité
cet homme de 71 ans
[Musique]
et c'est vrai bain de foule du symbole
vivant de la lutte anti-apartheid sans
aucune déclaration le couple mandela
prend aussitôt la route précédé d'un
immense cortège
direction l'hôtel de ville du cap à 60
km
les dizaines de milliers de personnes
sont déjà massés là attendant les
premières paroles publiques de leurs
leaders
l'admiration pour le combat et le destin
demander à quelle quel parcours quel
parcours et surtout de cette de cette
révolte de ce combat politique qu'il a
menée évidemment avant d'être
emprisonnés
ces années de prison et puis pour finir
un président qu à kayes bluey évidemment
le reste du monde par par sa sagesse par
la capacité à mettre en place un
processus politique que personne
n'imaginait un processus de de paix de
réconciliation de voile alors là la
situation en afrique du sud est loin
d'être résolues y compris sur le sur les
discriminations sur les mets waouh
quelle leçon quelle leçon politique
savez moi en 90 g/t au au burkina faso
et ça a été un moment en afrique mais
incroyable incroyable incroyable de d'un
espoir d'une
d'une sortie à la fois du
visa mans de l'apartheid pour la pour
l'afrique du sud mais d'une forme de
d'espérance incroyable parmi les
populations africaines aux ligaments
pour toutes les populations du monde
mais pour les populations africaines
c'est simplement quelque chose mais
avez-vous vous un modèle d'engagement ou
bien diriez vous vous avez vous même
tracez votre chemin en solitaire
n'entre à jamais son chemin en solitaire
n'existe pas ou alors on arrive dans une
impasse
mais est ce qu'il y à ce que j'ai un
mentor dont il ya des personnes qui qui
m'ont profondément
inspiré mais ça va de la politique
dany cohn-bendit évidemment quand on
fait la campagne de 2009 le combat qu'on
a pu mener avec josé bové
après c'est victor hugo je trouve est un
personnage absolument incroyable de
notre histoire politique culturelle
gisèle halimi
dont on qu'on devrait évidemment mettre
au panthéon
ce sont des ce sont des engagements qui
n'ont jamais
qui n'ont jamais failli
il n'y a pas longtemps demandé qui
devait les au panthéon alors je disais
gisèle halimi mais je pensais aussi à
albert camus
parce que albert camus c'est à la fois
des engagements très forts évidemment on
connaît son parcours à combat dans la
résistance
mais c'est quelqu'un qui au delà d'être
très ferme sur ses convictions a
toujours dit un moment quelles que
soient mes convictions et je ne lâcherai
jamais il faut que je vivais qu'on
voisins voyez à quelque chose qui à un
moment donné dit je dois garder l'amour
de mon voisin même s'ils pensent pas
comme moi et je devrai vivre avec lui et
je trouve que c'est une c'est une énorme
leçon de politique au moment où tout le
monde veut diviser moment tout le monde
pense que la radicalité s'est divisée je
pense que aujourd'hui la vraie
radicalité en politique ça doit être de
de rassembler les français de les
réconcilier
solitaire dans l'histoire il a été
souvent son ombre et son héritage plane
sur cette campagne vous voici à présent
yannick jadot face à de gaulle
nous sommes en 1963 le général de gaulle
exalte une arme et une énergie que vous
allez combattre le nucléaire
tu restes un critérium du moment à
critérium immédiate de cette
indépendance
cela est dans le domaine atomique il
s'agit de savoir si pendant que les
autres se sont fait quand il se faire
des armes capables de détruire l'univers
et nous aussi
il s'agit de savoir si nous aurons aussi
nous n'aurons pas nous aussi de quoi
nous défendre
nous avons décidé d'avoir ce qu'il nous
faut et d'autant mieux est d'autant plus
que cette puissance nucléaire comme on
dit est liée directement à
l'énergie atomique elle même qui est
comme vous le savez tous
le font de l'activité de demain le
nucléaire militaire et le nucléaire
civil dans le même discours est ce que
vous pourriez dire yannick jadot merci
mon général grâce à vous la france
possède aujourd'hui l'électricité la
plus décarbonés au monde
j'aurais du mal à dire ça je dirais
merci
alors c'est pas mon général là c'est
charles de gaulle il est président de la
république assure
merci charles de gaulle d'avoir démontré
que la france peut avoir une incroyable
politique industrielle peut former les
meilleurs ingénieurs les meilleurs
ouvriers investir pour atteindre un but
incroyable qui effectivement en un peu
plus de vingt ans on a construit un parc
de 58 réacteurs et on est devenu le pays
le plus nucléarisé
mais si vous voulez moi toute la
reconnaissance que je peux avoir pour
cette capacité à construire une
politique industrielle pour les
ingénieurs les techniciens les ouvriers
aujourd'hui je veux la mettre au service
d'une autre ambition qui je considère et
la vraie modernité c'est d'aller vers
ces énergies renouvelables ces énergies
de territoire ces énergies on assume au
fond la production dont on a besoin sur
son territoire et puis surtout qu'ils
sont des terrains
d'extraordinaire innovation c'est là que
veulent aller nos jeunes ingénieurs
c'est là que veulent aller depuis les
cfa jusque partout il ya cette capacité
à innover à inventer de dépendre du
soleil du vent de la géothermie de l'eau
plutôt que de l'uranium qu'on va
chercher dans des pays qui sont loin
d'être des démocraties le pt le le
pétrole du golfe où le le gaz de russie
donc c'est un formidable projet
d'innovation que je porte rubriques
suivantes
180 degrés comme les changements les
volte face qui émaillent les parcours
politiques en 2010 est loin de la
division d'aujourd'hui vous faites le
choix de l'union de la gauche en
retirant votre candidature au profit du
socialiste benoît hamon et vous en
appelez à jean luc mélenchon
pour la première fois l'écologie le
social l'europe et la démocratie peut
gagner une élection présidentielle alors
jean-luc parlons nous continuons à
travailler et créons cette grande
espérance autour d'un rassemblement
c'est pas facile je peux te le dire pour
moi ça n'est pas facile et bien mais
faisons le ensemble qu'est ce qui vous
donne le plus de regrets l'union de 2017
qui a débouché sur un petit 6 % au
premier tour où la désunion
d'aujourd'hui
écoutez j'ai tenté au printemps dernier
de rassembler tout le monde pour
travailler sur un projet
voilà ça n'a pas marché ni jean luc
mélenchon ni années d'agonie le
souhaitez mais ma conviction aujourd'hui
on est en 2022 c'est que on à ce défi
climatique et qu'il a déjà le chaos
climatique qui menace
l'inaction qui nous amène vers ce chaos
en 2022 il ne peut pas ne pas y avoir
cette candidature écologiste qui veut
être à la fois intransigeante sur le 5
degrés de réchauffement qu'il faut pas
dépasser la biodiversité qu'on doit
protéger et qui est à la fois
échappé à la catastrophe mais je les dis
créer un enthousiasme une mobilisation
une innovation une justice sociale
est au fond le pour moi l'écologie
aujourd'hui
c'est la vraie matrice du progrès c'est
comment à travers l'écologie ce qu'il
est les valeurs de liberté d'égalité de
fraternité
redevienne une langue vivante quand
elles sont trop souvent
devenu une langue morte ça ne répond pas
ma question il si les styles plus
regrettable dans la configuration
politique c'est l'union que
n'affectaient les grand chose en 2017 ou
la désunion d'aujourd'hui ce qui est
plus regrettable c'est qu'aujourd'hui
les progressistes et des humanistes dont
certains se cherche encore ne rejoignent
pas l'évidence qui est que l'écologie
est la vraie matrice de progrès
aujourd'hui et pas simplement de rester
dans des dents des conformismes dans des
demi mesures dans des ambiguïtés qui ont
été un échec avec le quinquennat olemps
malheureusement et donc moi je continue
cet appel à ce que encore une fois il ya
un rassemblement évidemment mais il ya
trop de confusion politique aujourd'hui
vous le savez il ya des urgences
absolues climatique sociale donc moi je
suis dans la clarté je suis dans la
clarté d'un projet fort crédible et qui
aspire maintenant à gouverner dans votre
parcours politique un autre coup d'éclat
un accident de parcours classé dans la
rubrique zéro pointé
c'est une des missions rase campagne en
2011 porte parole d'eva joly vous décidé
subitement de lâcher la candidate écolo
yannick jadot pressé de questions
c'était samedi dernier à paris tenté le
grand écart avocats de l'accord
électoral avec le ps et en même temps
porte parole d'une eva joly très
critique vis-à-vis du texte aujourd'hui
le divorce est consommé il démissionne
car il se dit en désaccord avec la ligne
politique d'eva joly
après un silence de quelques jours eva
joly est en effet passé à l' attaque en
ciblant le parti socialiste vous en
voulez à françois hollande j'en veux aux
socialistes tav a cédé aussi visiblement
aussi directement au lobby du nucléaire
lâcheté refus du compromis non pas du
tout au contraire on savait
j'accompagnais et d'ailleurs j'ai été un
des derniers accompagnés eva joly
jusqu'au bout de sa campagne même après
cet épisode là mais voilà le parti
europe ecologie les verts avaient décidé
de construire un contrat de gouvernement
avec les socialistes
qui est un contrat qui
portait des véritables avancées
malheureusement françois hollande a
décidé de s'asseoir dessus mais donc à
partir de là
la candidate écologiste devaient cibler
davantage nicolas sarkozy que françois
hollande avec qui on venait de passer un
contrat parce que cela me semble être la
logique politique donc il ya eu des
désaccords au sein de son équipe un
désaccord avec avec eva joly donc jamais
avait tiré les toutes les conséquences
mais vous savez j'ai encore une fois
j'étais un des derniers accompagnent eva
joly ça a été une campagne difficile
c'était une campagne difficile jusqu'au
bout mais j'étais un des derniers à ses
côtés voici à présent yannick jadot
quelques madeleines nous vous en avons
trouvé trois qui devrait vous ravir
comme vous êtes fan de western
on vous a mis de côté une des plus
grandes stars du genre qui explique la
différence entre le western est la vraie
vie je dirais à peu près la même
différence qu'entre les actions coups de
poing et de combat politique j'aime
beaucoup de jouer dans l'ouest
mon avis j'ai ma gueule les west s est
presque quelque chose grassi mais sait
on n'est pas très intéressant par sa
guerre dans cette époque la cia au
problème
enfin quelque chose me dit mot par
exemple si nous discutons quelque chose
si vous dit quelque chose
et mes démons je suis prêt aussi vous
êtes prêt et il y a morisod mais dans la
vie moderne si là il ya un problème
entre nous je parle avec mon avocat
nous sommes devant le juge il adoube
longtemps dans le west un tout
vous avez reconnu quatre glaces mais je
ne sais pas si vous vous reconnaissez
dans l'efficacité du cow-boy solitaire
qu'il vient de décrire écouter au fond
ce qu'ils racontent carglass il ya un
magnifique western qui en parle c'est
l'homme qui tua liberty valance et vous
avez john wayne qui est le western dont
parle kirk douglas et
vous avez james stewart qui est l'avocat
qui arrive avec le droit mais aussi
notre façon de faire fonctionner la
société donc l'homme qui tua liberty
valance raconte 7 7 7 cette évolution en
fait cette transmission ce changement
d'époque mais il ya un western
absolument fabuleux avec kirk douglas
parce que le bouquin est magnifique il
faut absolument le lire c'est la captive
aux yeux clairs
le bouquin c'est du tri qui là qu'il a
écrit et ça raconte ses magnifiques
parce que c'est l'histoire des trappeurs
aux états unis évidemment ils sont
tellement amoureux des grands paysages
ils vivent à moitié avec les indiens
et ils sont ils adorent ça mais en tant
que trappeur ils sont l'avant-garde de
la civilisation qui va tout détruire à
la fois les grands paysages et les
indiens et guthrie raconte ça d'une
manière d'une manière magnifique et de
grands films évidemment l'homme qui tua
liberty valance et le rio bravo et
johnny guitare qui est un magnifique
western féministe et comme il en existe
peu mais y en a de magnifiques
donc vous n'êtes pas un cow boy
solitaire en politique
je ne sais pas je il ya toujours une
partie un peu solitaire en politique
parce qu'il ya quelque chose d'un peu
d'à peu surnaturel ou non naturelle qui
comme sains de ceux de se mettre en
avant bien sûr il ya quelque chose il ya
un enjeu d'incarnation
mai mais c'est un sport collectif d'un
sport incroyablement collectif sinon ça
m'a ça n'a aucune chance est au fond ça
n'a aucun intérêt nous allons donc
dégainé notre deuxième madeleine vous en
avez parlé des belles cela vous en avez
pas oui vous en avez parlé tout ça de
romain gary et les racines du ciel l'un
de vos livres de chevet romain gary en
parle ici en 1956 je voulais montrer
comment cette protection de la nature
exige aussi la protection d'un drame des
droits de l'homme ou de certains élèves
de certains droits essentiels de la
version mais je le répète je n'ai à
aucun moment voulu faire vite
se présenter comme ça mais cette
indignation de morel vous la partagez
s'était entièrement élèves contre la
chasse aux phoques finalement je dois
dire que je crois que c'est à des choses
que j'aurais châtie le plus profondément
j'ai en écrivant ce livre je peux dire
que j'ai mené cette campagne à chaque
part j'ai à chaque instant mais j'avais
été plus sincères à chaque page d'un
livre que j'ai été en étrillant les
racines du ciel oui la vie dit tout à
l'heure que je crois à chaque ligne de
ce que j'écris
mais est il vrai que de faire croire aux
téléspectateurs que ce livre a pour
thème la protection de la nature fasse
n'est pas ça je ne mens pas le résultat
si vous permettez à quelques mots il
s'agit quelque chose de dire de tout de
rassurer quelques choix les exigences du
progrès de la marche à l'avant de
l'humanité quelle que soit la difficulté
de notre tâche est de quels que soient
les périls qui nous menace de nous
entendre et des éléphants c'est à dire
de laisser une marge suffisante tant que
certains tous les droits essentiels de
la personne humaine
tout ce qui fait l'angle tout ce qui
constitue notre patrimoine humain
essentiel depuis toujours soit
sauvegardée choix qu'elle paye quel que
soit le parti quelle que soit
l'idéologie quelle que soit la tâche
quelle que soit l'entreprise
quand on fait quelque chose de large et
le péril qui nous menacent il faut
protéger une foule nous a envoyé des
années par les éléphants mais bien au
delà on a vu bien nick shadow votre
plaisir à écouter les paroles de rama
yade tout je les avais jamais entendu
donc ça va j'ai lu à peu près
correctement son livre puisque c'est
comme ça qu si je l'avais interpréter
mais mais
quelle hauteur quelle hauteur incroyable
quelle vie incroyable aussi la promesse
de l'aube c'est absolument magnifique
emile ajar c'est magnifique romain gary
est quand même un des plus grands
écrivains français incontestablement
enfin sur les murs de votre chambre
d'enfants ou d'adolescents un poster de
l'ange vert dominique rocheteau héros du
football notamment mais pas seulement
pour ceux ce but de légende face à kiev
en quart de finale de coupe des
champions 76
[Applaudissements]
solidaires
10 passes et crever
[Applaudissements]
toute la défense et à donner
on est à une minute de la fin match
extraordinaire à geoffroy guichard
pourquoi rocheteau
parce que c'était c'était un attaquant
parce que
quand on est gamin qu'on adore le foot
c'est vrai que spontanément on va plus
vers les attaquants parce que en plus
ils étaient frais on n'est pas dans le
football d'aujourd'hui où les sportifs
sont quand même très très baraqué
c'était c'était une autre époque c'est
vrai que c'est votre terme de madeleine
convient bien c'est
c'est une équipe qui d'un seul coup
passe à la télé
les gens changer leur poste noir et
blanc pour pour la couleur pour voir là
la coupe d'europe c'est saint-etienne
c'est une cité ouvrière
et j'avais j'avais rocheteau et à côté
j'avais keegan cité le grand attaquant
de liverpool parce que c'était cd club
qui était incroyable c'était les cités
ouvrières et je vous invite à lire un
très beau bouquin de saint roman de
david pire sur rouge et aux morts qui
raconte l'histoire de l'entraîneur de
liverpool et qui montre à quel point à
cette époque la salle reste en partie il
faut pas dénigrer le temps présent mais
les joueurs avaient un respect infini du
supporters c'est à dire que le
supporters qui mettait un billet pour
aller au stade il devait au fond le
joueur lui devait son sacrifice toute
son énergie pour gagner et c'est vrai
que voilà ça correspond à ma jeunesse
moi je continuais adorait le foot
évidemment mais même si c'est un peu dur
pour saint-etienne en ce moment mais
mais ça reste mon club de coeur parce
que c'est ma jeunesse parce que c'est là
parce que c'est le foot parce que c'est
des émotions qu'on annule par ailleurs
en fait alors on quitte pas le vert avec
archives que nous soumettons à tous les
candidats
sur adn celle de l' alerte verte
archives tiré de la campagne
présidentielle de 74 ou un candidat
septuagénaire des jackass le ronron
politique pour nous alerter sur des
dangers futur vous savez ce qui va se
passer eh bien nous allons bientôt
manquer de l'eau et c'est pourquoi je
bois devant vous un verre d'eau
précieuse puisque avant la fin du siècle
si nous continuons un tel débordement
elle manquera à lundi je vous dis au
revoir et j'espère vous revoir pour vous
expliquer notre projet global d'avenir
merci mais hallyday
rené dumont pionnier de l'écologie
politique
yannick jadot pourquoi nos sociétés ont
elles mis si longtemps à prendre cette
cause au sérieux parce que c'est
difficile parce que c'est difficile de
se projeter dans un avenir qui peut être
catastrophique si on n'agit pas parce
que c'est toujours difficile de changer
ses comportements parce qu'on a des
habitudes on a des conforts et surtout
si on a l'impression qu'au fond
si le voisin le fait parce que c'est
vraiment utile si la france ne fait pas
ce que c'est vraiment grave et on peut
reporter comme ça les américains qui dit
si les chinois le font pas pourquoi nous
le faire et que ça s'inscrit dans le
temps donc ce qu'il faut arriver à faire
aujourd'hui c'est à démontrer que à la
fois changer ses comportements
c'est se faire du bien c'est nous faire
du bien collectivement mais
changer ses comportements ça suffit pas
c'est un quart de la réponse envoyée
115% ce que les trois quarts de la
réponse sont les politiques publiques
donc on voit rené dumont dans l' alerte
évidemment aujourd'hui l'enjeu c'est de
prendre le pouvoir c'est de prendre le
pouvoir sortir du déni mais pour sortir
du déni il faut créer un enthousiasme
à la fois répondre concrètement dire le
chemin et dire que tout le monde sera
sur ce chemin là que ça se fera d'abord
au bénéfice des des plus fragiles
victime de du dérèglement climatique
victimes de la pollution de l'air
victimes de la malbouffe et ça se fera
d'abord à leurs bénéfices et non pas à
l'ordre est actuellement dernière
rubrique de cet adn une rencontre
en voyageant dans le temps et les
archives de l'ina et nous vous proposons
donc cette rencontre la personnalité que
vous allez voir et entendre s'appelle
françoise d'eaubonne elle a inventé
l'écoféminisme dont certains aujourd'hui
se réclame dans votre parti nous sommes
en 1971
en réalité je crois que nous arrivons
envers une époque beaucoup plus
révolutionné en profondeur qu'on ne peut
l'imaginer et que précisément ce qui
sera certainement la marque spécifique
de 7 à venir s'asseoir à une époque où
les différences secondaire que jusqu'à
présent on appelait virilité et féminité
tout à fait arbitraire noms seront
complètement dépassés au profit de la
totalité de l'humanité nous allons vers
la totalité dans tous les sens
monsieur
oui il y en eu les mines le différend
président je crois que ça c'est la
question c'est toujours l'objection
comporte les sociétés on est une
hiérarchie dans ce mode il s'agit de
fabien margie je manquais conférence
heure actuelle et justement quand on
parle de différends sur la très bien ce
qu'on pense on voit quelque chose du
genre du meilleur des mondes et des
anticipations fantastique qui nous font
dresser les cheveux sur la tête à savoir
d'une espèce d'uniformité qui serait
embêtant ce n'est ce pas c'est bien ça
or à mon avis c'est justement voir même
le problème car je crois que demain
cette négation la différenciation
blanche parle au lieu de se traduire par
une uniformité se traduira au contraire
par une synthèse et si vous voulez au
lieu de l'être asexué dont on peur ce
qu'ils entendent parler de ce genre de
choses on aurait au contraire un être
doublement sexué donc on ne peut plus
que ray si vous voulez toutes les
qualités des deux sexes il y aurait plus
l'homme viril la femme gracieuse et
settat pour prendre très grossièrement
les styles idée des styles dépassé
gilbert que chaque être humain serait
mais dont viril et gratuit à la fois
françoise d'eaubonne qui prône non pas
la prise de pouvoir par les femmes mais
la gestion égalitaire d'un monde à
renaître une sorte de
déconstruction si vous voyez ce que je
veux dire cette reconstruction on voit
bien qu'on a reconstruit rousseau notre
société autour de de l'égalité de la fin
des discriminations
on a des destins des vies des parcours
qui sont abîmés simplement parce que
dans notre imaginaire collectif il ya eu
comme des termes qui ont été empruntés
dans le on est de retour chez polak
de hiérarchie
c'est terrible pour encore une fois
c'est l'humiliation là on abîme d'aider
des millions de personnes parce qu'on
les ramène à une identité qui qui est
une force et qui ne peut pas être une
une condamnation qui peut pas être une
stigmatisation qui peut pas être un
handicap donc une société d'égalité qui
n'est pas une société uniforme qui est
une société au contraire de diversité
est une société qui est une société qui
riche où on enrichit les parcours
individuels et on s'enrichit les uns les
autres donc il ya encore ya encore
beaucoup de boulot on a des propositions
justement pour avoir une assemblée
nationale 50% femmes 50% de garantir
l'égalité des salaires de lutter contre
les violences faites aux femmes ça reste
ça reste un combat mais on voit que
c'est un combat qui n'est pas née
d'aujourd'hui on voit que c'est un
combat qui a une histoire c'est qu'on
sait combattante et qu'on doit continuer
à poursuivre parce que franchement on
peut pas être dans des sociétés où
l'autre est une menace l'autre est une
différence l'autre c'est toujours un
enrichissement au terme de cet adn
yannick jadot y at il un morceau de
votre adn que nous avons manqué au
sûrement sûrement sûrement sûrement
c'est à vous de le dire on parlait tout
à l'heure de la picardie
c'est vrai que moi je suis né de parents
instituteurs je suis né dans le logement
de fonction de l'école
et c'est vrai que ce voilà mes parents
étaient très républicain quoi c'était
important à l'école et c'est vrai qu'à
l'époque j'ai eu l'occasion de retourner
à l'école communale les enseignants qu'à
fermer malheureusement les enseignants
étaient été reconnus étaient respectées
l'école était davantage respectée et
puis la picardie c'est c'est le chemin
des dames moi j'ai juste à côté d'où je
suis né c'était le chemin des dames donc
c'est aussi ça notre notre histoire de
france en fait ça à la fois la
république la promesse républicaine
et puis des sacrifices qui doivent nous
nous inspirait pour une compris quand on
voit les tensions qui aujourd'hui dans
le monde pour construire un monde de
paix voilà merci yannick jadot merci de
votre invitation merci de ces images
[Musique]